so we could talk about fauci going off
oh
yes they're sacrificing fauci this is
really interesting to see
so i mean this is me doing like basic
research but um
basically rogan had a dude on his
podcast
that started talking about excuse me
rogan had doing his podcast
that started talking about um fouchy's
connection
to what is it called something game
games gain of function research
into covid viruses or coronaviruses okay
and gain and function research is they
basically like juice up the coronavirus
yeah and to see how
uh vaccines would work against it okay
okay so they're like if we make it on
steroids
would it the vaccines still work right
and they stopped this under obama
because they thought it was dangerous
because they're creating a virus
that we won't have any cure for and if
that got out of the lab
it could potentially kill a lot of
people right maybe even cause a global
pandemic
in 2017 under fouchy's tutelage because
i guess he's the guy that has to sign
off on all these things right they
continued that research so now this is
under trump right
so fauci the guy who's coming out and
saying like yo trump uh got rid of the
uh
pandemic team or whatever the [ __ ] it is
is also the guy who's like yo we started
doing this wild ass research again
that research um was happening in the
in the wuhan lab right and was funded
through an organization that i believe
fauci
uh has to give the sign off on
so i think they find it to the tune of
like six hundred thousand dollars
and um through it's it's kind of like
murky but i guess it does eventually go
back to fouchy
right so they're funding this research
in the wuhan lab and i guess there were
a few people that worked in that wuhan
lab that did get sick with something
and were hospitalized after getting sick
with something
and being hospitalized i think this is
in november right at the time if i'm not
mistaken
so it looks like
this whole pandemic was started from a
lab leak
from gain of function research now this
is important
for a couple reasons one fauci said
there's no way that that happened he was
all about the bat theory right
it's a bat these chinese people eat bats
and we're so [ __ ] racist we're just
like yeah of course they bats like
this is how this [ __ ] works and
we all believe that and he shot down
this idea that it came
from gain of function research or it was
genetically engineered
now the reason why it's important is
because i think when indian scientists
first looked at it they said this looks
genetically engineered
australian scientists first look at
they're like yo this looks genetically
engineered like i think we made this
[ __ ]
or somebody made this [ __ ] and it was
shot down not only was it shot down
if you said that it looked genetically
engineered on social media
they brought down your posts apparently
like fauci and i think uh
zuckerberg spoke and zuckerberg's like
yo how can i help with like the
information that's going out here
and i think the conversation was we
should yank down
anything that says that this is man-made
because it's not man-made
it comes from bats there's all these
press conferences where he's basically
saying
this virus is consistent from when uh
from coronaviruses that could have gone
from a bat to a human being and that's
what it would look like right
when he very well knew that that is
[ __ ]
so he was not only lying to the american
people
being exalted as this [ __ ] hero in
the process
but also ripping down quote unquote fake
news or misinformation
there was existing all these social
media platforms
that actually could have given us a
little bit more understanding of what we
were actually dealing with
and put some responsibility on the
people who [ __ ] it up in the first
place
obviously it leaked in the lab in china
which is [ __ ] up but if we're funding
that research
we're partially responsible too it's on
both i mean don't get
wrong the end-all be-all is probably the
lab because you have to take the safety
precautions necessary so these [ __ ]
viruses don't go out
and cause a global pandemic but if we
know that they're not taking those
precautions and this lab isn't good
enough to do this research
why the [ __ ] are we funding it yeah so
it's a really interesting situation
where fauci has been
you know kind of like deified during
this whole process
but the reality is he knew some [ __ ]
that he wasn't sharing with us
and allowed himself to become a [ __ ]
you know what is it a
pandemic god yeah and wrote a [ __ ]
book it seems like everybody writes a
book during the pandemic ends up [ __ ]
up big time like cuomo wrote a [ __ ]
book
this guy wrote a photo i don't know
where they get the time to write their
[ __ ] books but point being
yeah i mean like they're got to
sacrifice the guy the dems got to
sacrifice the guy all these people who
are like the fouchy enthusiast they
gotta sacrifice and the guy [ __ ] lie
gotta go bare minimum lied bare minimum
am i missing anything here mark
i mean it's we can't necessarily
conclusively say that
the lab leak theory is like confirmed
it's not confirmed
but all of a sudden it's way more
plausible it's also worth denoting that
like
the idea that it's man-made versus like
humanly modified
is not necessarily synonymous with a lab
leak
like inherently so like people are like
oh it's a bio weapon from china
and they made it on purpose and then
leaked it out to like affect the world
and that's not necessarily what this
theory is it would be an accidental leak
right and the accident that the virus
actually is naturally occurring however
it's just modified and like the spike
proteins were modified just to see
like the gain of function research yeah
research stuff so it's like
to be more nuanced it's difficult to say
that like it wasn't yeah it wasn't done
with malicious intention
even on fauci's parking gain of research
china's part it leaked
you could say this whole thing happened
one thing i kept saying early on is like
i'd be having hunches i said i don't
know how this isn't man-made
because at basic ass science i was like
okay early on it causes a cough
it affects your lungs you might need
oxygen then all of a sudden i give it to
giannis he's [ __ ] his brains out
and it's affecting your digestive system
then people are fatigued now they're
losing your sense of smell
none of these things i know to be linked
there's a digestive system
there's a respiratory system yeah how
the [ __ ] is this affecting everything at
once
that doesn't seem naturally occurring to
me yeah that was my only logic but i was
like it seems like it has to be man-made
for that alone
yeah so this doesn't i'm it's very easy
for me to be like yep this [ __ ] is
man-made
accidentally leaked absolutely cool yeah
but it was man-made
yeah the other things to note like in
defense of fouchy is that people are
looking at people that emailed him
and suggesting that like oh fouchy knew
that's like the big trend
like read it in twitter like oh fouchy
knew this voucher knew that yeah but
it's like just because someone emails
someone
doesn't necessarily mean a that they
read it to that like they digested all
the information that they're privy to
all of it
fauci knew that people believed right
that it was mammoth there's no way in
hell yeah of course that he didn't have
a single conversation
with somebody said it looks as if this
was man-made right
he in order for him to conclude the bad
theory
he has to discredit man-made theory
right and he had no way to discredit it
there was enough time to do the actual
research
i just think it was a way better
narrative to go this came from a bat
than potentially the research that i was
funding that's fair
and that's what i think people are being
upset at him about they're like of
course you said it's bad
because if it wasn't bad they gonna look
into the numbers and see that you put
six hundred thousand dollars into that
[ __ ] lab where the [ __ ] leaked out of
[ __ ]
and then more more so to his lies like
someone asked him i think rand paul
asked him have you ever did this lab
ever engaged in gain of function
recently he said no
and he said on the stand under oath
so i don't know if that's a semantics
thing that like oh technically this lab
wasn't working on gaining functional
research if it's not technically gain of
function research
is actually a different type of research
exactly he could get off on like uh what
is the term
uh technicality technicality right he
could get off on a technicality but
it is interesting what's happening man
you know we're all about to turn
on on anthony fauci you know what else
this calls and question people who were
like aids is man-made
and i remember my cousin telling me if
you look at this virus doctor he said if
you look at this virus
i can see how people think it's man-made
like it's so perfect
and i remember a lot of people being
like word y'all say this [ __ ] came from
that's a dave chappelle joke word
a monkey somebody has sex with a monkey
and then a human
and now that to me seems like oh it
seems like a very plausible cover-up to
just say oh this came from an animal
it came from a bat it came from a monkey
when in reality it could have very well
been man-made
maybe not for nefarious uh and with
nefarious intentions but the [ __ ]
could very well have been man absolutely
and then it could have leaked as well
yeah yeah that's another to me the most
fascinating part from like the all the
email leaks which like
frankly i think the headlines over
exaggerated what was presented
yeah but the biggest thing was this guy
peter dasik okay is that he
was apparently funding research at the
wuhan lab and then he was also
coincidentally the person that wuhan
hired or that the who hired
in order to create like the uh who is
the world health organization yeah in
order to do
investigative research on like the
origins of the guy who's funding the
research that ends up causing the global
pandemic potentially right also just
happens to be the guy that the who
hire to investigate the lab
where the pandemic leaked out of right
of course you're not going to get an
honest investigation
and i mean there was a lot of criticism
of the who during this period
i'm not trying to say that you know
trump is right about that but he was
critical
but it could be right that's right he
could be right he's okay he could be
right
he could be wrong about a million other
things you say the same thing about alex
jones alex jones could be right
yeah you know but he could also be wrong
about a million other things
yeah so then basically he get like
fouchy gets an email
the day after he's on fox news or some
major news network
promoting the like uh bat to human
theory
and discrediting like the lab league
theory this guy peter dazek
he shoots him an email goes yo thank you
so much for you know sharing the truth
and
you know discrediting the lab week
theory which obviously is false blah
blah blah
and so him being in fouchy's emails
thanking him for
his work and contributions to clearing
up the narrative so to speak
i thought was particularly interesting
now where do you go with that
i mean basically what you just said like
this guy is like potentially responsible
for funding research
potentially new more than the average
person as to like the origins of the
the virus and then is thanking people in
high places that are
using their platform to try to help him
you know get out i wonder if china and
america had a conversation
and they're like yo we're both
responsible for this [ __ ] maybe
it came from a bat yeah maybe like
you guys funded it you guys want to do
this research it happened to be over
here
yeah um there's a specific thing and i'm
i have a note here for it i'll actually
look it up but like
there was a certain level of security
that was necessary
for this type of research security not
like
people know about it but actual like
physical security like there's a certain
like health requirement right it was
code it needed to be code four
but they were only at like code two so
to continue doing it
at that level is dangerous because it uh
there's not many barriers to exactly
there are more opportunities for a leak
so they weren't even updating the lab
for the necessary precautions
so who knows but it is interesting what
if both of both parties are like listen
we're both [ __ ] up here
we're gonna say it came from a bat
because if it came from a bat there's
nothing we could do they'll make fun of
you about your wet markets you can shut
down the wet markets for a few weeks big
[ __ ] deal
but the reality is the whole world got
shut down because of some american
research
in asia in a chinese lab yeah and
you know i was just about to say that
goes to what i was going to say which
was
the they're sacrificing fauci obviously
because there's no way he's
the highest ranking person that knew
about this there were a lot of people
above him being like
yeah you [ __ ] up bets this can't be
on america this can't be on china that's
so who
who's above him that's what i'm trying
to understand like tim
you brought up trump if i'm trump and i
appointed this guy i would trump didn't
it would be he's been in he's been in uh
i thought you said his 2017 so it was
one trump
oh and it came back when trump was in
power but he's been working for the
government for the last like 30 years or
something i think jimmy carter
yeah he was popping during the aids
epidemic okay so when the research came
back that could still fall back
epidemics just started with him like he
might be the architect
he was around her spanish blue probably
son jasmine
is there to start pandemics that's his
job that's his [ __ ] job maybe he's
dana
ebola sars mers that [ __ ] was
down for all of them aids
aids as well that's when he really
started to make his name maybe he's
trying to help us though
maybe he's trying to help us or maybe
he's the guy that's put in there to [ __ ]
[ __ ] up
exactly well he's trying to get rid of
the he's trying to get him oh he's
trying to
call the bro he's thanos the herd oh my
god
fauci is [ __ ] thanos man wow comes
through with the gain of function
wow snap snap wow anyway it's just
interesting times to see this happen
because he was such a [ __ ] hero and
people are about to flip on his ass so
goddamn quick
so what do you think happens he gets
locked up nah no no
these guys never get locked up yeah
because locking him up would mean
personal accountability for america
yeah yeah right it's a weird thing like
we're
we're tied and the people above him that
allowed this to happen because if
if you if one of us does some horrendous
[ __ ] that's still on you
yeah you know what i mean so it's kind
of in your bedroom just to be like all
right man let me take care of keep the
[ __ ] quiet let me take care of this it
also proves all the right wing guys
correct you know what i mean like
they're loving this [ __ ] the trumps the
rand paul
ted cruz like yeah they're all
vindicated because the whole time they
were like this guy found she didn't know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about they
were talking mad [ __ ]
even before they knew anything they were
just like yo [ __ ] him forever but i get
that
i get that because the guy was making
decisions that really weren't based on
anything he was doing
what i thought was the best what i
thought
he was doing what he believed was the
best uh decision for the time making the
best decisions for the time yeah right
like
that's what every governor anybody in
power did right some were overly
precautious
and then some were maybe not precautious
enough right right like some people
would criticize desantis about that down
florida they'd be like oh man
you should have had more people with
mass you should have done it maybe you
could have saved even more lives
right and then people were critical of
cuomo for the the opposite reason they
allowed people to go broke you allowed
people to go back to people's lives
they might be alive but they have no
livelihood 100 yeah 100
so i always assumed the best with
voucher i was like he's being safe
because that's his job is safety
yeah his job is not supposed to be hey
go out there and wing it that's not what
scientists do
you go to your dentist he tells you to
brush your [ __ ] teeth three times a
day and flossing that's
always bothered me not always i read it
a few months ago it's like a new york
times
summary of an article i read the whole
[ __ ] obviously i'm me but
they said something like they knew early
on masks helped and i remember them
saying mass don't do anything and i
bought into it but i was like
math should help yeah and they said that
because they wanted to save masks for
frontline workers so they just told all
of us mass don't do anything
instead of saying the real reason which
is hey
if you told us that you were saving it
for frontline workers we would have
bought all them shits
there's a run on mass toilet paper all
over again but at least at least you
have to
acknowledge that you not you be them you
set the precedent of lying yeah
you said the president lies so why
should we believe you once you lie once
we can't believe you no more
we're always going to be skeptical and
you give the people who want to buy into
the narrative that this the whole thing
is a hoax etc etc you gave them the
ammunition yeah
whether i agree with them or not i can't
disagree with the fact that you gave
them the ammunition by lying off rip